kobrakai's third season is full of
tension and surprises
kris takes over cobra kai with no mercy
daniel and johnny team up
and all three sensei confront their
pasts as they prepare to settle their
present-day differences
let's break down the explosive ending
and what it may mean for season four
after robbie makes miyagido infamous for
what happened during the school
melee in season two daniel finds that
his karate themed advertisements
aren't so cute anymore as his car sales
begin to drag
his top competitor tom cole secures an
exclusive distribution deal with doyona
and offers to buy daniel's dealership at
a bargain price
but daniel decides to take a trip to
japan instead
after an inauspicious meeting with
toyona daniel visits mr miyagi's home
in okinawa and reunites with kumiko the
young woman he defended
and had a romantic relationship with in
the karate kid part 2.
kumako has several surprises in store
for daniel
at tomi village including mr miyagi's
old love letters to her late aunt yuki
and a visit from the now grown woman he
rescued from a typhoon as a child
she's now vp of international sales at
doyona and as a long overdue reward for
saving her life so many years before
she steps in to save his business
relationship with the company
not only does the larusso auto group
come out of their pr nightmare
relatively
unscathed in the end but they also
convince anush to return to their team
and find that cousin louis is actually a
pretty solid salesman
with the dealership on solid ground once
again daniel will be able to focus on
his more personal matters going forward
another familiar face kumiko brings back
into the picture
is that of chosen who daniel defeated in
a brutal fight in the karate kid part 2.
rather than holding a grudge however
chozen wants to make amends
chozen reveals that his sensei sato was
also trained by miyagi's teacher
so he has inherited several artifacts
from miyagi's dojo and wants to test
whether miyagi really taught daniel
everything he knew
during a match chosen stuns daniel by
striking several pressure points and
disabling his limbs
a maneuver he attributes to miyagi's
teachings after pinning daniel
chosin ends the fight by honking his
nose which is a playful nod to how
daniel ended their vicious bout
so many years before chosen admits he
has felt shame for his behavior back
then
and is relieved to learn that daniel has
forgiven him in return
chosen agrees to train daniel and
miyagi's powerful move
and also gives him a cherished scroll
from miyagi's collection to take home
not only does daniel walk away with a
newfound peace agreement with chosen
he's also armed with a very effective
new defense technique
[Music]
only every rival we can end like this in
addition to saving his business
and learning a new trick in japan daniel
also gets some closure with kumako
though the two had an intense connection
in okinawa all those decades ago
they lost touch with one another and
moved on with their lives
the two lament the fact that they might
have kept in contact more
easily in the modern era of social media
but they part on great terms
kumako isn't the only ex that daniel
gets to finally say goodbye to
either ali also returns to the picture
after she and johnny reconnect on
facebook though johnny has finally begun
a romantic relationship with miguel's
mom carmen
he can't resist the chance to catch up
with his high school flame the two spend
a whole day together having fun at lunch
and an arcade and she takes him to a
country club party that daniel
also attends you remember johnny
lawrence
right how can i forget
ali is bemused to find her former flames
fighting just like old times but
correctly calls them out for being more
alike than they'd like to admit she
also accepts daniel's apology for ending
things so abruptly and thanks johnny for
making her feel young again
before wishing him well with carmen the
memory of fighting over ally has always
been a point of contention for daniel
and johnny but now that the two have
gotten a chance to talk things out with
her
they can finally let go of that piece of
their animosity
and the truth is you guys are more alike
than you want to admit
johnny and carmen aren't the only new
lovebirds taking flight this season
it looks like miguel and sam are also
ready to octopi
some space together again too after
training with johnny
miguel is back in fighting shape and
returns to school
sam apologizes to miguel helps raise
money for his treatments and even shows
him around
miyagi dough the site of them together
might make robbie incensed and it even
raises eyebrows with daniel but sam and
miguel share more than just some
smooches
together they hatch a plan to unite
their dojos for the greater good
meanwhile demetri and yasmin have become
unlikely kissing buddies
not that she'd ever admit that in public
of course and something is definitely
brewing between robbie and tori
after robbie is released from juvenile
detention he and tori bond over their
equally crummy upbringings
and their mutual dissatisfaction with
the idea of miguel and sam
getting back together whether these two
will combine their anger to form a
butt-kicking power couple remains to be
seen
but based on the looks they give each
other in the final episodes we wouldn't
be surprised if their relationship
is about to heat up off the mat
at first miguel has trouble convincing
the members of johnny's new eagle fang
dojo to join forces with sam's miyagi
dome members
but once the kobra kais attack them all
at their christmas party the battle
lines are officially drawn
this means former besties turned rivals
mitch and chris
and bert and nathaniel can finally fight
together again
instead of forcing themselves to hate
each other perhaps the most surprising
member to join this new team
is hawk he is initially poised to be
cobra kai's new champion
and takes kris's tough teachings to
heart even breaking dimitri's arm during
an off the mat confrontation
all season long though hawk watches with
disdain as crease recruits most of his
least favorite people to join the dojo
including his former bully kyler and
robbie
who hawke still blames for what happened
to miguel
look i know some of these guys and
they're natural athletes
which is exactly what's been missing in
our dojo hawk participates in the siege
on miyagi doe
but upon seeing his teammates attacking
his former friends
he decides to switch sides and defends
dimitri against having his arm broken
again
he takes dimitri's side at miyagidou for
the first day of dual training with
eagle fang
making it clear that these two are
finally ready to fight side by side
after so much turmoil after the
kobrakai's attack the unsuspecting kids
at miyagidou
johnny decides to confront his former
sensei once and for all
he's surprised to find his son robbie at
the dojo rising to crease his defense
but johnny still engages crease in a
fight that very nearly turns deadly
robbie discourages johnny from using a
sigh on kris
after he gains the upper hand and kris
makes him pay for that moment of mercy
after robbie himself tries to pick a
fight with johnny
johnny accidentally knocks him out
against a locker
and crease nearly chokes johnny to death
however
daniel arrives in the nick of time and
kicks crease off of johnny
after a brief fight daniel uses miyagi's
disabling move to stop crease in his
tracks
kris suggests that instead of this
turning into a death match
they finish the fight by entering their
students in the all valley tournament
they all stood up to save
if cobra kai loses kris promises to
disappear from town for good
while johnny and daniel unite to take
crease down however
crease maintains one last trick up his
sleeve
throughout cobra kai season 3 we finally
learn why crease is so hell-bent on his
strike first and no mercy philosophies
after enduring the death of his mother
and bullying in his workplace
young crease finally fought back when
one of his tormentors hid his girlfriend
betsy who then became chris's girlfriend
he signed up for a tour in vietnam
shortly after
and was recruited for a covert mission
alongside his friends
ponytail and twig tragically the entire
unit was captured
on that mission ponytail was immediately
executed
while the others were made to fight one
another to the death above a pit of
snakes
kris's captain who regularly accused him
of cowardice
was chosen to fight twig and kries
volunteered to take twig's place
the captain nearly defeated kris after
he revealed beth had died in a car
accident
but kris gained the upper hand even as
they were saved by air support
kris kicked the captain into the pit and
declared he'd finally learned his lesson
show no mercy twigg who may not have
seen kris kick the captain
told kris that he owed him a life debt
and would always be there for whatever
crease needed
now it appears kris is finally ready to
collect after crease makes his deal with
johnny and daniel to settle their
disputes at the tournament he makes a
call to an old friend
while holding a photo of himself with
ponytail and
twig check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one